good morning uh welcome all here to
Public Works and highways room I am the
acting chairman of the long-range
Capital planning utilization committee
uh time being a little after 9 30.
so we will start with the organization
of the committee
we will nominate a chair a vice chair
and a clerk and at this time I would
call on representative Cloutier did not
for a nomination uh Mr chairman I
nominate representative Mark McConkey to
be chair of the long-range Capital
planning utilization committee thank you
get in first and second
are there any other nominations for
chairman
seeing none we will close if you're in
favor uh representing or representative
McConkey is being chairman signified by
saying aye
aye if you're opposed nay
um thank you and I accept chairmanship
uh nominations are now open for vice
chair and I would recognize Senator
Pearl good morning Mr chair I would
nominate Senator Lang for vice chair
thank you
um Senator Pearl nominates Sandra Lang
for chair for vice chair is there any
other nominations
seeing should there be a south second
then I didn't hear a second Mr chairman
okay thank you
uh sectioned by cluder or any other
further nominations
seeing none if you're in favor of um
Sandra Lang being Vice chairman uh
signified by saying aye
aye aye those opposed
passes unanimously
we will now accept a nomination for
Clerk and I would look to representative
Cloutier uh Mr chairman I nominate
representative David Mills to be Clerk
of the long-range Capital planning
utilization committee Russia Mills has
been nominated and I will second
so he's made in second are there further
nominations for Clerk
seeing none if you're in favor of
Representative Mills being clerk
signified by saying aye aye those
opposed
hearing none it passes unanimously thank
you so you now have a chairman Vice
chairman
and Clerk and thank you all for that
we will move on there are we have
minutes here from November 28th 2022
that have been distributed
um
it should be in your packets
we have a motion to accept those minutes
as distributed
so moved by Senator Lang
uh any discussion on the minutes
Corrections or missions
seeing none if you're if you're um
in agreement for the acceptance of
minutes November 28 2022 signify by
saying aye
aye those opposed
we have no old business which is item
number four
um as we will move now into new business
number five uh speak to project
23003 Department of Transportation
request authorization to sell 0.70 plus
or minus an acre
state-owned land located on the
Northerly side of New Hampshire Route 25
in the town of Effingham
um
sure if you would address this request
thank you Mr chairman my name is Steve
Labonte I am the administrator of the
Bureau of right-of-way I'm also an
advisory member to this committee uh as
designated by commissioner Cass uh the
department is seeking to sell 0.7 of an
acre of state-owned land located on the
northeast side of New Hampshire Route
125 in the town of Effingham to the
stilling lanes revocable trust Eric
Jones trustee for fifteen hundred
dollars which includes the statutory
1100 administrative fee the subject
property is a portion of a larger parcel
acquired in 1987 for the construction of
New Hampshire route 25. at the time the
department acquired 6.38 Acres from
Claire Louise sonat for 33 500 via
warranty deed after a departmental
review it was determined that this
property is Surplus to the Department's
operational needs
uh the parcel itself is is oddly shaped
it has no independent access and is uh
mostly wet
as a condition of the sale the grantee
will be required to commission a
licensed land surveyor in the state of
New Hampshire to conduct a survey and
prepare a perimeter boundary
serve survey plan which will be recorded
at the registry of deeds the grantees
shall be responsible to obtain all local
and State land use approvals and there
will be no access as mentioned before to
Route 125.
um if um
an appraisal was conducted
by a staff appraiser and it was
determined that the contributory it has
no Standalone value so it's it's
contributory market value as of November
7 2022 was four hundred dollars
I can take questions if anybody has it
seeing none was the pleasure of the
committee
yes move to approve 23003
thank you uh Senator Lang moves to
approve
23003 seconded by Mills
any further discussion
um the disposal of a 0.70 acre of land
in Effingham signified by saying aye
aye those opposed
yeah we are
we're in the middle of our committee
will start in a few minutes
okay we'll move on to item
23004 Department of Transportation
requests authorization dispose of
.062 plus or minus an acre state owned
land located Northern side of the Range
11111a in the town of Windham please
thank you Mr chairman
the department is Israel requesting
authorization to dispose of 0.062 of an
acre State on own land located Northerly
located on the northeast side of Range
Road in the town of Windham the sale
will be direct to CE Properties LLC for
23 100 which includes the Eleven Hundred
Dollar administrative fee CE Properties
LLC is under agreement with crystal ball
Enterprises to purchase the abutting
parcel once the subdivision process is
complete there's a larger plan involved
with this sale
um the department has been working with
the town of Windham to ultimately turn
over route 111a and reclassify it to a
class 5 Highway then the town of Windham
will take over maintenance
responsibilities for that as part of
that
uh discussion the department has agreed
to discontinue the former route
111a which if you look at the plan it
kind of skirts off into a larger parcel
of property
um
so as part of that once that
discontinuance is complete under the
middle of the road Doctrine what happens
it's a prescription not it's an easement
highway so under the middle of the road
Doctrine
that old road is split in half and it
goes to each of the two of Butters that
the the remaining property so it'll go
to the parcel that's a budding route
111a and then as the state the other
side will go to the state
so we were contacted by Crystal Ball
Enterprises to sell this property we've
been working with them for I think since
2019 they've gone out they've they're in
the subdivision process now
um
this parcel was acquired in 1961 and it
was part of a larger
larger parcel and we paid eight thousand
six hundred and fifty dollars for it
um
so the property has a contributory value
of 22 000. now this is a small awkwardly
shaped
uh P property so in the interest of
transparency this is
kind of an interesting uh disposal so in
December of this year another party
surfaced and I I just want to be clear
because the other party may have come
maybe here today and may wish to address
the committee so I I just want to be
clear about that so another party has
has come and they've expressed interest
in the property
so
their purpose for their their purpose
for wanting the property is for
conservation
but it has no conservation value really
what it is is this person wants to buy
the property to restrict access to that
larger parcel and
basically it's a gorilla tactic to stop
the otherwise legally permissible
development of the parcel the department
has clearly told them now we're going to
proceed with the sale to
um
CE properties
so I just I wanted to be clear that
there is this other party out there who
has an interest in it so I can take any
other questions thank you
um are there questions from the
committee
it I'm going to say it's nice to see
that for once we're making money on a
parcel so thank you for that
um so pleasure of the committee
so as moved
moved by Lang segment by Pearl
Sanders
if you're in favor of the motion to for
the sale of
.062 Acres
um as item number
23004 signified by saying aye aye those
opposed motion passes thank you
next item sir is uh
23005 Department of Transportation
request authorization to sell 0.75 acre
state-owned land limited access
right-of-way on the southern side of
u.s3 Daniel Webster Highway to the town
of Belmont
if you would please thank you Mr
chairman as you just stated we're
seeking authorization to sell 0.75 of an
acre of state-owned land within the
limited access right-of-way located on
the southerly side of U.S Route 3 in the
town of Belmont
winnisquam storage LLC contacted the
department
and is looking to buy the property to
expand their storage facility
the parcel is a portion of a larger
unimproved parcel that was acquired in
1972 from Granville and Dorothy Robinson
be a warranty deed for thirty six
thousand dollars
the
at the time of the acquisition the that
that
parcel was 1.53 Acres was improved with
a two-story structure that housed a
laundromat in an apartment building that
structure is no longer there
um the department after Department
review it was determined that the
property is Surplus to the Department's
operational needs as a condition of the
sale the
um when a Squam storage will be required
to commission a licensed land surveyor
to complete a survey and prepare a
boundary line
plan
grantee when it's gone storage will be
responsible for obtaining all local and
state land use approvals no access will
be given to Route 3 and uh yeah
based on the current conditions of the
parcel and appraiser an appraiser has
opined that the contributory value as of
January 9 2023 is forty nine thousand
four hundred dollars
seeing none what is the pleasure of the
committee
considering this is in my district and
I'm happy to return this back to the tax
rolls I moved to approve 23005.
motion made by Lang sector by Cloutier
um if there's no further discussion all
those in favor will signify by saying
aye
aye aye those opposed nay
motion carries unanimously
last item under new business uh
23006 Department of Transportation
requests authorization to sell 1.18 plus
or minus Acres of staying on land
located Westerly side New Hampshire
Route 3 and north of the Merrill Access
Road in the town of Thorpe to be sold to
the town of Thornton
if you would sir thank you Mr Mr
chairman
um the department is seeking
authorization to sell 1.18 acres of
state-owned land on the Westerly side of
New Hampshire Route 3 to the town of
Thornton for eight thousand dollars plus
an eleven hundred dollar administrative
fee
the parcel is a portion of two is is a
portion of two Parcels with a combined
area of
98.04 Acres acquired from Vincent and
Geraldine levasser by condemnation in
1968 for 20 450 dollars as a as a
condition of this cell
the town will be required to commission
a licensed land surveyor in licensed in
New Hampshire to complete a survey and
prepare a perimeter boundary line plan
that will be recorded in the registry of
deeds based on the current conditions of
the parcel and appraiser has opined that
the contributory value as of December
30th 2022 is eight thousand dollars
thank you questions
yes Senator Pearl thank you just looking
at the map and I'm kind of curious why
you cut the corner off so much on that
is that for a future widening of the
intersection likely so what happens is
we will when we get an inquiry regarding
a piece of property what we'll do is
we'll prepare what we call a
departmental review and
um
what then happens is we send out this
this packet similar package of what you
got here we send it out to our Bureau of
Highway design our Bureau of Highway
Maintenance Bureau of environment Bureau
of planning and also Bureau of
Aeronautics and Rail and Transit
then they'll come in and comment so my
guess is and I'm not sure likely
maintenance probably came back and said
well we need this for either to maintain
it or Highway design came back and we
should keep this for future widening
thank you
seeing none
um pleasure of the committee on item
23006 move to approve
um
motion made Mill seconded by Lang for
the approval
to sell 1.18 acres of state-owned land
located in Westerly side
Westerly of New Hampshire Route 3 North
of Merrill Access Road in the town of
Thornton
any further discussion
if you're in favor of the motion 23006
is signified by saying I I those opposed
nay
motion carries I would like to I would
like to back up on an item I missed I
have two items
Mr Shea on 2302
revised status yeah so again
um the packet
23-002 is just a compilation of the
various rsas this committee May
encounter through the items that come
before you so it's just a One-Stop shop
for that
the second item that you had from us is
a it's a looks like a cover letter
and behind that is a it's called
guidelines and procedures so this
committee has typically approved a
series of guidelines that they would
like the agencies to adhere to when
disposing of property
um the I can go through each
point or the committee can read it
all right I'm sorry go ahead so the
number one is basically that the sale
price
um when negotiating that shouldn't
fluctuate more than 10 percent from the
amount that the committee has been
presented to the committee
when you're when the Departments are
determining a broker commission there's
thresholds for their percentages under
for um commissions for properties with
improved buildings it limits it to five
percent or that's what's recommended
and then the last two things are more um
for our office it's if you need um
an item on the agenda you need to get it
to us no later than two weeks before the
scheduled meeting otherwise you gotta
request a permission from the chair to
so again these were things that the
committee has adopted in previous
sessions again the first four items
three items are to provide guidance to
the agencies on
when they want to dispose of a piece of
property what they should consider
any any questions of Miss Shea
seeing them thank you
Mr chair then I moved to accept the
guidelines and procedures as written
thank you motion made by Mills seconded
requires requires action
if you're if you're in favor of the
motion signify by saying aye aye aye
opposed nay it was a late item brought
in
and under informational we have
three items you can read those at your
pleasure or if you have questions on
yes just a cheer me I just make one
quick comment
um I don't the informational item 23-001
that's the biennial report that's
required of the long-range Capital
planning committee so this is the
compilation of all the projects that
were approved to be disposed of or
leased during the last uh session two
sessions you'll have a similar report at
the end of your time on this committee
so as you approve items such as you did
today we'll check back in with the
agencies near the end of the legislative
sessions to see if they've disposed of
the properties that the values that were
discussed or not and provide a final
report to you thank you
Sandra Lang that's typically put
together by the Vice chairman yeah
seeing none I would like to as we did
previously set tentatively the date of
our next meeting for
May
that was the 2016 May 26th thank you a
Friday it's a Friday
and and what time would that be Mr
chairman it would have a same starting
time as we did today which I believe was
nine nine thirty okay thank you Mr chair
yes I have a another Solid Waste working
group meeting that was is at 9 30 on
that morning so I may have a conflict
all right well let's uh if it turns out
to be more conflict than that then we
will uh we will work on a different day
Senator Waters had a possible conflict
also for our earlier meeting so with
that
um any other business before our
committee
I will call this move to adjourn motion
made to adjourn second and by Cloutier
all those in favor signify by saying aye
aye aye those opposed nay we are